as klay thompson rushes up the floor
durant quickly to the basket with
authority
love the outlet pass to james
what a sequence that was speed and how
about
jefferson over thompson big time play it
is great to see that mr jefferson is
still moving on up
hurry on irving
irving the drive back to james
cavalier's lead and a foul
ahead now but irving steals it back from
duran
irving gets in the paint scoop layup he
banks it in
drives on thompson irving spins puts up
the shot it's good kyrie irving with 3.4
remaining and the warriors call timeout
irving does it again to the warriors
odom first and here comes kobe out into
the picture and shaq
with a little elbow but never looked at
him look right over the top of kobe's
head
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the one problem when you are a
center you're at the merger now brian
from outside three-pointer going choice
last year driving to the basket and gets
fouled three and kobe bryant three-point
land and 21 rebounds the other night
against the hornets
baby
[Applause]
got it back puts it in i want to tell
you
starts to get doubled right now
jones on him gets the screen from him
and
[Music]
kobe goes all the way to the hoop and
runs into guess who
that was an excellent move by brian
brian saw a hair check
[Applause]
i really like backing up on them again
to turn around and this one neil has
made that move and score elevation and
you know what they could do
he's guarding bryant
damon jones ready to come over and help
so kobe launches
jack forces
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
anderson
[Applause]
you have to clear out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foul
[Applause]
the thunder
[Music]
duran topped the screen and durant with
the bucket
the exact shot that we saw kevin durant
just his second game of the season
coming off a knee surgery and he brings
so much to this team with his energy and
heart and offensively is a bonus with
kenya mark but it is good to see him get
going early in the game
[Applause]
but you can't teach speed and speed wins
out at the end of the day and ty lawson
provides plenty of it and he can get to
places on the floor because of that
durant creating from the top and a tough
shot
defensively this year they're right
around 20th so you see the drop off he's
talking about four seconds to go in the
period
[Applause]
who else
[Applause]
kevin durant that his penetration led to
that shot initially because he converged
four defenders kicked out and then
relocated and oklahoma city lost tracked
off and he ends up with a wide open
three in the corner it had been a rather
quiet second period for kevin durant
before that bucket what it's all about
the great burgeoning stars here in the
nba finished second in the league in mvp
balloting last year and with shots like
that if there's a lot more of them which
surely there will be
he'll have a shot at it but enough about
what
[Music]
it's under down five
they go right back to durant
working against aflalo a good defender
but he does it to a lot of good
defenders
as good defensively as the flallow is
he's against the flallow his second what
i'm talking about right here
you can't really play it any better than
this you force him to the baseline the
hand is there but at the end
a little two-man game with kristich
great ball movement durant for three
and the thunder to within one
frustrated right now just jumped off the
bench and imploring his team let's go
meaning keep somebody in front of you
because right now denver is just living
at the rip
and the thunder living on the
three-point shooting of durant that's
his second in a row world championship
gold medal winning team for team usa
this past summer
here's durant
he has 11 in a row
now and again he could just demoralize
you because a flop
approaching five minutes to go in the
third quarter
a big third quarter for durant and he
continues to sizzle just lighting it up
right now
talk about an offense smith
martin
a little bit out of his range and a
chance for the thunder to take the lead
westbrook
and one
second time tonight we've seen the
combination in reverse
with durant leading the break in the
middle westbrook acting as the finisher
it's one of the advantages we talked
about that size that he has at that
position getting to the rim
doing big work here and big things in
the third
gary forbes right now trying to lock him
down
and the operative word is trying
and that's the ability right there that
makes him so special the fact that he
might have waged him late it's the
giving season and he's giving him plenty
trust me off the dribble with the fade
here moving without the basketball
something not enough scorers in this
league do dribble handoff three-point
shot for your 6-10 player mid-range
pull-up game and then the post-up
aplalo's doing all he can to stay with
them but durant just made a number of
difficult shots you see the break back
in the lead by one
miranda's hit
nine of his last 11 making 10 of his
last 12 field goals what do you do to
see if they go back to the zone or back
in the zone now if oklahoma city
moves the ball and
kevin durant says enough ball movement
right there didn't really
with his type of game he just has a
picture-perfect release on his jump shot
and it's made him so dangerous because
now he could just go out beyond
the defense
that might just about do
two of the game's biggest stars on the
stage and ron james continues to be hot
that's a three-pointer
[Applause]
throw it down baby
lebron james another three that's good
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a combination of michael jordan
dr jay and george gervais on the same
plane
mcgrady jumps out
and it's another three
lebron james there's mcgrady guarding
him
oh
[Music]
lebron james again
and tracy mcgrady and lebron james have
been nothing short of spectacular plays
the blast
butler with dogged defense on irving
kyrie
kept his dribble alive tough shot uh
uncle drew with another one
let me tell you
that was a raindrop
what a tough shot butler was right on
top of them
the sixers can get the last one
tied at 108. simmons out front
guarded by morris
watch this shot watch as he gets down in
here he doesn't have anything but now
i'm gonna go right up with a little fade
irving for three
yes and the lead i really like that the
way they set that up
look out here
irving for three
whoa
wow uncle drew strikes again
[Applause]
you